il a fini l'école tu as prévu quoi après
l'été j'en sais rien j'ai donc décidé si
t'as rien prévu de mieux à la fin de
l'été que tu t'engages ray dans l'armée
à six semaines pour décider de ce que tu
vas faire le ta vie armée ou parme et tu
feras toujours partie de l'équipe pape
acura représente je ferai un meilleur
soldat que toi mon pote c'est peut-être
moi qui devrais m'engage on vous ressort
du plumard on se lève entraînement tu me
prends pour une bille
je vais pas m'engager dans l'armée après
qu'est ce que tu vas faire d'autres la
danse de quoi un vrai boulot c'est un
vrai boulot les gens se font beaucoup
d'argent en voyage partout dans le monde
les gens comme des copains du boulot on
a vu son clip c'est pas mal qu'elle
pense que tu as qu'il faut pour
rejoindre notre équipe ils veulent
m'auditionner mecque pour être dans la
meilleure équipe de dix morts
tu crois que j'y vais t'enterrer oui le
meilleur danseur de nouvelle zélande
vous avez six semaines avant le régional
pour montrer ce que vous valez bien
danseurs qui a du talent des cheveux
vrais manques tu entres dans la cour
j'avais pas que tu t'en c'est comme ça
le classique c'est pas la tasse de thé
de kate parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
lever la jambe si rock c'est ça tout est
amoureux d'une fille de la côte
aujourd'hui dernière occase pour vous
montrez que vous êtes motivés ils te
prennent pas ça dépend de toi je te vire
est c'est une foutue dans son équipe
bourgoin des toits mais pour moi c'est
la victoire